we begin this morning with President
Trump in Seoul South Korea after
wrapping up the g20 summit in Japan
after posing in the class picture with
other world leaders mr. Trump said trade
talks will resume with China and that
he's holding off on imposing new tariffs
on China at least for now in the last 24
hours the president has met with the
leaders of two of America's biggest
rivals Russian President Vladimir Putin
and Chinese President Xi Jingping Paula
Reed is in Osaka Japan where mr. Trump
discussed these meetings and a whole lot
more
good morning Paula what can you tell us
good morning Michelle earlier today the
president tweeted an invitation for
North Korean leader Kim jong-un asking
him to meet him at the border between
North and South Korea so the two men
could shake hands and say hello tomorrow
we're going to the DMZ I said while I'm
there
I'll shake his hand we get along at a
press conference in Japan shortly before
he departed for South Korea President
Trump said he hoped to meet with North
Korean leader Kim jong-un and would
gladly step on North Korean soil sure
feel very comfortable doing that I would
have no problem earlier he held a high
stakes meeting with Chinese President Xi
Jinping as the two countries are engaged
in an escalating trade war
the two men were unable to reach a deal
but the president cited some progress we
agreed that I would not be putting
tariffs on the 325 billion dollars that
I would have the ability to put on if I
want it he said both sides made
concessions China agreed to buy more US
farm products and the US will make it
easier for Chinese students to study in
America the world win of diplomatic
engagements came on the sidelines of the
g20 summit yesterday the president met
with Russian leader Vladimir Putin where
he appeared to joke about election
interference
today he revealed the two leaders
continued to discuss Russian meddling
during their private meetings we talked
about it hey we talked about her you
know we've talked about it before you
know he denies it totally special
counsel Robert Muller concluded Russia
did in fact interfere in the election in
an effort to benefit mr. Trump former
President Jimmy Carter suggested
yesterday president Trump's 2016
election victory was illegitimate he
lost the election and he was put in
office because they Russians anything on
his behalf Russia isn't it crazy okay
Jimmy Carter look here's a nice man he
was a terrible president he's a Democrat
and it's a typical talking point during
his time at the g20 the president met
with other controversial leaders
including Saudi Arabian Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman
he says they discussed the murder of
us-based journalist Jamal khashoggi
killed in the Saudi consulate in
Istanbul last year nobody so far has
pointed directly a finger at the future
king of Saudi Arabia but the CIA and the
UN have both assessed the crown prince
ordered to show Jesus a nation a North
Korean official described the prospect
of a Kim trunk meeting at the border a
very interesting suggestion if the
president was to step into North Korea
he would be the first sitting US
president to do so Jeff